[Musique]
féminines semaines qu'on dort dans cette
banque est parce que parce que dans
notre chambre basse est plus possible
on a fait une ouverture de fenêtres et
on n'aurait peut-être pas dû et ce qui
fait qu'en fait on a beaucoup on a des
odeurs de gaz falloir rebondir et du gaz
on pensait que c'était du gaz de ville
parce qu'après on ne sait pas on sait
plus on est perdu donc on est pris de
picotements dans la gorge de nez qui
comme si on respire est vraiment du
froid picotements dans les yeux et puis
constante fatigué maux de tête à moi
c'est les bronches ça me prend les
bronches ça me ferme le nez ça me fait
très très mal au bon j'ai l'impression
d'étouffer en fait tout doucement je
vois plus clair
voilà boire quand guillon qui sont
arrivés là récemment des problèmes de
ventre très mal l'estomac je pense
d'après moi c'est le stomacaux voilà
s'est garé bon ca de gars et ça fait
deux ans que j'ai à dire et quoi lâcher
ça fait deux ans que je fais que comme
normal bon voilà quoi
tout simplement puis après mon bac quand
on va voir votre médecin qui pratique en
gros c'est environnementale bon bah
voilà ça n'arrête à la c
environnementale un air irrespirable des
mots insoutenable des douleurs de plus
en plus fréquentes
c'est inné cyril ont repris la
briqueterie artisanale il y a neuf ans
ils travaillent tous les deux dans la
petite usine installée à côté de la
maison
au début tout allait bien mais leur rêve
d'une vie de famille à la campagne a peu
à peu tourné au cauchemar quand les
odeurs de gaz se sont infiltrés partout
notre cour était renfermé part
par des bâtiments voilà donc une fois
que ses rentrées là ça ne sort plus
comme ça c'est compliqué à faire sortir
voilà donc ça rend dans le fond de
l'usiné ça reste en fond de grille sinn
on rentre ça va très bien du maître
après on vomit ses curiosités quoi voilà
fatigue et résignés ils sont à bout de
souffle
même s'ils sont inquiets pour leur santé
et celle de leurs enfants ils n'ont pas
les moyens d'engager une procédure
judiciaire
on a contacté un avocat enfin une
avocate et qui nous a dit clairement que
de toute manière rien et est probable
que que voilà c'était c'est très très
difficile c'est des analyses qui sont
déjà de très longues à faire nous
personnellement on aura ni la force
morale ni la force physique de d'aller
plus loin en fin de de fer quelconque
procès qui pourrait durer jusqu'à cinq
ans pour prouver quoi est-ce qu'il ya
quelque chose à prouver enfin on ne sait
plus on et voilà et en plus de ça on n'a
pas d'argent à pernes parce que ça fait
donc deux ans que les usines tournent au
ralenti est due à ses problèmes de santé
l'a donc au jour d'aujourd'hui nous on a
pris la décision de partir respire
ailleurs de trouver une habitation pour
aller respirer ailleurs aux heures de
fermeture de notre entreprise et revenir
travailler donc voilà comme tout le
monde pourrait faire quand il fait beau
travail quoi
est ce une coïncidence si lyn et cyril
vivre à trois kilomètres du centre
d'enfouissement de veolia à saint palais
chaque jour des centaines de camions
déversent des milliers de sacs poubelle
dans d'immenses alvéoles ces sacs
d'ordures ménagères seront ensuite
écrasé et enterré
laetitia vite elle aussi à côté du site
de veolia
elle a quitté la région parisienne pour
vivre à la campagne mais depuis un an
toutes les semaines
elle aussi subi des émanations de gaz de
plus en plus insupportable quand les
odeurs elles sont devenues encore de
plus en plus violente
parce qu'il ya des fois et surtout moi
dans ma salle à manger si vous voulez
j'ai pas de chappe
si vous avez vu c'est donc en fait il y
pleut après quand l'on remonte
vous venez chez moi ça sent la mort
comme s'il y avait un cadavre sous ma
maison ça sent une odeur de putréfaction
ça me prend ici j'ai l'impression
franchement caillaissé la fin que je
vais passer
j'ai mon corps qui tout le bras qui sont
bourdy j'arrive plus à des malaises
oui et surtout surtout moi ce qui
m'atteint vraiment c'est les yeux mes
yeux c'est quand ça se met vraiment les
odeurs elles sont vraiment là je peux
même pas les ouvrir les yeux parce que
d'églises ou ça me brûle mais c'est
horrible
jésus injectés de sang et c'est horrible
quand on peut parler d'eux
de ce qui se passe autour et tout ça les
médecins tout de suite hier à aulas est
en fait on passe plus pour des fous et
j'ai l'impression qu'on n'est pas pris
au sérieux
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de lésion
après enfin il ya déjà des symptômes et
qui ne restent pas moisir qui quand on
s'en va ailleurs passe mais par contre
aux firmes mesure du temps et dans le
temps on s'est passé ces lésions là si
on reste continuellement ici à long
terme si ça va pas rester rester pour
toujours quoi on va pas reste y est on
ne restera pas il faut qu'on parte
hattstatt magali vite avec sa fille dans
l'ancienne maison de ses parents
au début il n'a pas pensé à la proximité
de la décharge
jusqu'à ce soir d'hiver qui tourne mal
pour lille où ma fille a été quand même
presse de migraine de plus en plus
régulièrement jusqu'à un malaise un soir
peut-être lié ou pas effectivement un ça
mais bon qu'est ce qui s'est passé en
fait vous étiez là où parut mais oui
très mal de tête et puis les ton album
est évanouie et il y avait aussi ces
odeurs là oui mais oui oui c'était très
fort à ces moments là donc peut-être
effectivement dû à tout ça et elle a eu
également des ganglions nous et des
intestins
il n'y a pas si longtemps c'est la
première fois que je voyais ça des
médecins est un petit peu aussi une
ville hôpital et un petit peu surpris
dans un premier temps
l'explication ils en ont pas eu des
symptômes inquiétants et le doute qui
s'installe
je pense que ils sont courants s'il ya
des conséquences et des dangers
je pense qu'ils sont courants faut dire
la réalité est honnête il ya un problème
on my à un problème d'accord moi je
pense qu'il ya des moyens de le traiter
faire attention à l'eau comme je vous
disais la boire plus boire l'eau du
robinet s'il ya besoin de mettre des
masques un petit peu quand on sort
suivant le temps si c'est très fort et
c'est pour protéger mais je trouve qu'il
ya pas de prévention il n'y a pas de
l'information particulière de plantation
ces émanations de gaz toxique à forte
dose incommode toujours les habitants
pourtant pour la rs l' agence régionale
de santé
les résultats des derniers relevés faits
par véolia sont rassurants et valeur de
gaz détectée sont inférieurs aux seuils
toxiques
le risque d'exposition est donc
acceptable sur le court et de long terme
à saint palais on ne trie pas les
poubelles on enfouit les déchets ultimes
en les stockant sous terre pour bien
comprendre la méthode utilisée par
veolia il faut se représenter un
millefeuille de 18 mètres de haut
on creuse la terre en profondeur on pose
d'une membrane géotextile ensuite on
recouvre de cailloux et de déchets les
cailloux permettent de filtrer les
lixiviats ce sont les jus de poubelle on
ajoute une couche d'argile une deuxième
membranes et de la terre végétalisée
enfin un réseau de tuyaux certains y va
créer le biogaz dû à la fermentation des
déchets on est bien conscient qu'il ya
eu des problèmes d'odeur c'est un gaz
qui est très odorant à des très faibles
doses par contre qu'on a pu démontrer
c'est qu'il n'y avait pas d'impact sur
la santé aussi bien sur des périodes
très courtes où les gens peuvent
ressentir des odeurs importante que sur
des périodes très longues d'exposition
de plusieurs mois plusieurs années donc
on a démontré qu'ils n'avaient pas
d'impact sur la santé par rapport aux
événements odorant que les riverains de
saint palais ont ressenti ces épisodes
odorant proviennent du gaz h2s du
sulfure d'hydrogène d odeur d'oeuf
pourri très toxique et même mortel à
forte dose pour réduire ces émanations
veolia cette équipe est de 7h cher
mobile elle accélère la combustion des
gaz dans l'air des améliorations des
travaux contrôle et de très près par les
autorités
et on voit que même lorsqu'il ya eu des
pics on est très en deçà du seuil de en
effet fixé par la préfecture
nous avons bien conscience de la
situation nous avons mis en oeuvre des
moyens pour réduire et on est toujours
dans cet objectif là on continue à
surveiller réduire on sera là pour faire
les travaux nécessaires si ça devait se
reproduire je peux pas dire qu'il y en
aura plus jamais mais on est là pour
être vigilants pour veiller et on
travaille à réduire comme on l'a fait
depuis 2004
[Musique]
gisèle habite à 6 kilomètres du centre
d'enfouissement preda cher professeur de
sport la retraite
amoureuse de la nature elle aime
cultiver ses 300 orchidées faire son
jardin potager et courir en forêt sauf
qu'elle a dû modifier son parcours et
changer de rythme
des tournées en forêt qu'on sent le gaz
on regrette d'habiter là
[Musique]
oui parce que vous sentez vous sentez
l'odeur donc forcément c'est pas normal
moi je suis là pour respirer le bon air
pur pour m'oxygéner mon mari habiter à
paris donc il a fui paris pour pouvoir
vivre à la campagne dans un autre
environnement et on s'aperçoit que c'est
pareil
presque d'habiter à côté de ceux du
centre c'est aussi nocif que d'habiter
dans le centre de paris
gisèle souffre d'une sinusite chronique
depuis deux ans mais elle continue à
courir dans la forêt de saint palais
tous les jours le gaz suit les allées
c'est incroyable si les pouvoirs publics
s'ils font quelque chose c'est pas assez
s'est passé parce que la nature il faut
la préserver et on en a besoin les gens
veulent veulent
deux veulent se promener ils veulent
vivre correctement et ici on ne peut pas
on ne peut pas et je pense que c'est
pour nos enfants c'est pas bon
tout l'art à partir du 6 et où veolia et
sur le côté gauche et à la ferme la
caroline le lieu-dit la caroline
exposition et l'école alain et éleveur
depuis 20 ans ses chances se trouve à
quelques mètres du stockage de déchets
sa femme delphine est assistante
maternelle à domicile
tous deux ont assisté au début de
l'exploitation du site
très vite les odeurs de poubelles sont
devenues intolérables toute la famille a
souffert de migraines et d'insomnie le
couple est l'un des premiers à avoir
tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
on a fini par
menacé d'aller porter plainte à la
gendarmerie de déposé des mains
courantes et là on a été un petit peu
plus pris au sérieux mais il a fallu
menacé et puis est encore pris au
sérieux
ça c'est vraiment et 20 à ranger entre
guillemets quand quand la population
beaucoup plus large a été a été
concernée je vous avais depuis quelques
années des quelques malformations sur
les veaux soit la naissance
des quelques voix veulent et puis
beaucoup plus d'avortements que
auparavant les vaches qui avortent
auprès alors à l'automne c'était pas
prévu avant ça fait quatre ans qu'on se
bat quatre ans qu'on nous mène en bateau
quatre ans qu'on me dit que ça va
s'arranger et quatre ans qui trouve
toujours des petits soucis derrière et
que ça aggrave la situation
donc nous on n'y croit plus il ya des
moments oui enfin on en a vraiment ras
le bol et nous on peut pas partir on ne
peut pas le mari travaille sur place
voilà on va pas quitter le travail de
monsieur parce que veolia nous pourrit
la vie entre guillemets donc c'est vrai
qu'il ya des moments c'est un ras-le-bol
c'est un ras-le-bol et on n'a plus envie
il existe 250 centres de stockage de ce
type en france si les médecins
psychiatres à paris elle connaît bien
ces nuisances
elle possède une maison de famille en
haute-loire à côté de la décharge de
ville marché elle non plus n'a pas été
prise au sérieux
vous envie de vomir tout ça c'est dans
la tête sauf que je suis psychiatre je
peux dire que aussi dans la tête
le fait de vivre dans cette ambiance est
effectivement profondément anxiogène et
des précieux gêne parce que on a honte
on sent la poubelle n'allait pas en soi
même on devient un peu comme aux
poubelles avec d'autres habitants ci lui
a créé une association droit à l'air pur
d'ap 43 après trois ans de combat
juridique la décharge a été
officiellement fermée le 31 décembre
2016 une victoire une revanche qui ne
résout pas tout selon elle je pense
qu'il ya un retard de prise de court en
considération du danger et de ce que
vivent les gens exposés à cette
proximité immédiate et contre quand même
les écouter leur faire passer un bilan
médical et faire a minima une sorte
d'épidémiologie locale
le site d'enfouissement sera exploité
jusqu'en 2027 puis il restera sous la
surveillance de veolia pendant trente
ans après ce délai la terre restera en
friche
aucune construction ne sera possible une
terre condamné à côté de la forêt de
saint palais
[Musique]